CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So
last time we finished
by proving Bolzano's
intermediate value
theorem, which states that a
continuous function achieves
all values in between
the function evaluated
at the endpoint.
So if I have a continuous
function, neither--
I take a value y between f of
a and f of b, so either f of a
is less than f of b
and y's in between
is bigger than f of a and
less than f of b, or f of a
is bigger than f of b, but
y is still in between them.
Then there exists c in the
interval a, b so that f of c
equals y.
So every value in between f
evaluated at the endpoints
is achieved.
I drew the picture
that went along
with this a, b, f of a, f
of b, and that could be--
and if we take
anything in between,
then there has to be some
c so that f of c equals y.
At least in the
picture, I've drawn
there's three different
guys, but there's always
at least one.
And then the last
thing we talked
about at the end
of last lecture was
that the image of a closed
and bounded interval
by a continuous function is,
again, a closed and bounded
interval, where e corresponds
to the absolute max of f,
and f corresponds so that--
I shouldn't call this f since
we already have f being used--
let's make it d--
corresponds to the
absolute min of f.
So it's what we proved last
time is that if f is continuous,
then there exists
e, d and r, such
that the range of this
closed and bounded interval
is, again, a closed
and bounded interval.
So f is very well-behaved on
closed and bounded intervals.
And we'll see another way in
which continuous functions are
well behaved on a closed
and bounded interval in just
a second.
Now, a simple application of
the Bolzano intermediate value
theorem is the following--
really is an application
of that theorem
that I labeled the
bisection method.
But let's chalk that up to
the Bolzano intermediate value
theorem, which is the
following that if f of x
is any odd polynomial, then
f has at least one real root.
So any odd polynomial has
at least one real root.
So by the fundamental
theorem of algebra,
every polynomial has exactly
n roots, n corresponding
to the degree of the
polynomial, but these roots
can be complex valued.
But for odd polynomials, there
must be at least one real root,
and this is a consequence of
the Bolzano intermediate value
theorem.
But instead of proving this
theorem in its full generality,
let me just give you a
representative example.
So let's take f of x
equals x to the 2021 minus
x to the 2020 plus--
I don't know.
What's today?
I think the 25 or 24.
I don't know.
--1025x minus 300.
So what's the point?
As long as I plug
in a big enough x,
this will swamp everything here.
So, for example, if I
stick in f of 100,000,
I leave it to you to check
that this is positive
because this will be 100,000
to the 2020 minus 100,000
to the 2021, and
then plus this, which
will be positive minus 300.
This doesn't matter.
So what really matters is this
guy with the largest power
will swamp all the other
ones and eventually
be positive if I stick in a
large enough positive value.
In fact, for this guy, if I
stick in a negative value,
then I get something
very big, but now
with a minus sign,
which will again
swamp all these earlier guys.
In fact, I don't have
to choose minus 100,000.
If I just stick in 0,
I will get minus 300,
which will be negative.
But you can check that if
I stick in minus 100,000,
this will still be negative.
Thus, by the intermediate
value theorem,
there exists a c in
100,000 so that f of c
equals 0 because 0 is something
in between f evaluated
at these two endpoints.
And the idea is the same is that
as long as you go far enough
out and positive, then the
polynomial will be positive
if the coefficient out
in front is positive;
and if you go far
enough out negative,
then you'll get something
that's negative.
And then you apply the
intermediate value theorem
to be able to find a root.
Now, of course,
one other thing we
did with the statement of
the min-max theorem was,
can we drop any of the
assumptions on this theorem?
And you can see that
the example is no.
So the question is, if f from
a closed and bounded interval
is not continuous and, let's
say, f of 0 is less than 0,
f of a, f of b is
bigger than 0, then
does there exist c, a, b,
such that f of c equals 0?
Let me put that question
mark at the end.
And it's easy to come up with
an example of a function that
is not continuous that
satisfies these conclusions,
and there does not exist a
point in between so that f of c
equals 0.
Simplest being, I'll
just draw a picture.
Let's go from minus 1, 2.
So then the function is
f of x equals x minus 1.
And this is for x not equal
to 1, and let's make it a 1/2
there.
So this function
looks like 1/2 there.
So there is no value,
there is no c in between.
So x is between 0 and 2.
So you see f of 0 is equal
to minus 1, that's negative;
f of 2 is equal to
1, it's positive;
but there exists no c in
between, so that f of c
equals 0.
So what's the point I'm making?
We really do need
this hypothesis
that the function is continuous
for this theorem to be true.
If you drop that
hypothesis, then the theorem
is no longer true.
So now we're going to move
on to a new concept called
uniform continuity.
And before I do this,
I'm going to rewrite
the definition of continuity.
So this is an old
definition, but I
want to highlight a
specific aspect of it.
So this is me writing
the definition
of a continuous function again.
So function f from a set
s to r is continuous.
So we said that means it's
continuous at every point,
meaning if for all c And
s, it's continuous at c,
which means for all epsilon
positive, there exists a delta.
And we saw this in examples
that we did proving continuity.
This usually depends on
epsilon and c, the point where
I'm looking at, such
that for all x and s,
x minus c less
than delta implies
that f of x minus f of
c is less than epsilon.
So this is, again,
a bit of review.
But I just want to show
you that, in general,
when we verify that a function
is continuous on a set,
we have to show it's continuous
at every point in the set.
And that means for every
epsilon, there exist delta.
But this delta usually
depends on epsilon,
but it can also depend on
the point c, which is where
we're checking continuity at.
So for simple
example, let's take
f of x equals 1 over x on
the open interval 0, 1.
So I claim f of x equals
1 over x is continuous.
So proof we have to show
that for every c and 0, 1
for all epsilon,
there exists that.
So let's see b and 0, 1,
but epsilon be positive.
Again, since this
kind of review,
I'm not going to go through the
process of really the thinking
behind choosing this delta.
I mean, there's calculations
you do off to the side
to try and get this delta.
But let's choose delta to
be the minimum of c over 2
and c squared over
2 times epsilon.
So what I want to
again emphasize
is this delta depends on c,
the point we're looking at,
and epsilon.
So I claim this delta works.
Suppose x is in 0, 1, and x
minus c is less than delta.
Then absolute value of x, this
is by the triangle inequality.
Let me write it this way.
c absolute value is
equal to c minus x
plus x, which is less
than or equal to c
minus x plus x, which is less
than delta, which is less than
or equal to the
minimum of these two.
So it's certainly less than
or equal to c over 2 plus x.
And now c and x, these are in
0, 1, so they're all positive,
and therefore I get that--
Let's go to the next board.
So if I subtract the c over
2 over to the other side,
I get that c over
2 is less than x.
So this is as long as
x is in 0 and x minus c
is less than delta.
This should not be a shock.
There's 0, 1, c, c
over 2 3c over 2.
And so if x is in this
interval, it certainly
bounded away by c over 2.
Or if x is in here, then x is
certainly bigger than c over 2.
And now we look at
f of x minus f of c.
This is equal to
1 over x minus 1
over c equals c minus x
over x times c, which is
less than delta over x times c.
And now x is bigger than c over
2, so if I take 1 over that,
I get 1 over x is
less than 2 over c.
So this is less than or equal
to 2 delta over c squared,
and delta is the
minimum of now c over 2
and c squared over
2 times epsilon.
So this is less
than or equal to 2
over c squared times c squared
over 2 epsilon equals epsilon.
So I just went through
the proof of continuity
for 1 over x, which using better
machinery we could have proven.
But I did this to
highlight this point that's
showing continuity
of 1 over x on 0, 1,
that in showing that, this
delta that you are choosing
depends on the point
you're looking at.
So what the definition of
continuity says is for all c,
for all epsilon,
you can find a delta
depending on epsilon and c.
Now, uniform continuity
removes that necessity of delta
depending on c.
And I'm going to make a possibly
bad analogy in just a minute,
but first let me write
down the definition
of uniform continuity.
Let s be subset of r,
f going from s to r.
We say f is uniformly
continuous on s
if for all epsilon positive,
there exists a delta depending
only on epsilon, such
that where all x, c and s,
with x minus c less than delta,
we get that f of x minus f of c
is less than epsilon.
So a function being continuous
means that for all epsilon
you can find delta depending
on one of these points,
depending on c so that if I
had this, then I have this.
Uniform continuity
says you can find delta
that works across the board.
So I'm going to try and make
an analogy that hopefully I
don't have to cut
out of this lecture.
But it's a bit like this.
Let's take a trip
down memory lane
and imagine being at a party.
So you know everybody's
in the party
and let's say that
everybody can hear,
their ears work
just about the same,
and the goal is to
try and understand
each other's
conversation, try and hear
each other's conversations.
Now, in order for me to hear
this person's conversation,
depending on how
loud they talk, I
have to be close enough
to be able to hear them.
And this changes from person
to person in the room.
Maybe I can stand a foot away
from this person over here.
Maybe this person over
here is a low talker
and I have to be
almost up in their face
to be able to hear them.
Maybe that person
just whispers and I
have to be almost nose to
nose to be able to hear them.
That's a bit like a
function being continuous.
The threshold of hearing what
they're saying is the epsilon
and I have to change my
delta depending on what point
I'm at so that I can hear them.
Now, uniform continuity,
is kind of like everybody's
more or less speaking
around the same level,
speaking at the same loudness.
So I just can be within,
say, one foot of everybody
and be able to understand them.
Go to this person if I'm within
one foot I can hear them well.
If I go to this person
and within one foot
I can hear them well, and so on.
So that's kind of at
least a loose analogy
of the difference between
continuity and uniform
continuity.
So this is a reasonably
interesting definition.
So we should see
examples and negate it.
First off, you should be
able to convince yourself
that a function that's
uniformly continuous
is actually continuous.
I'm not going to write
the proof of that down.
It follows essentially
straight from the definition.
But let's look at a function,
which is uniformly continuous.
So the function f of x equals
x squared on the interval 0,
1 is uniformly continuous.
So what's the proof?
I want you to notice
I'm going to use kind
of in a very essential
way that we're
on this closed and
bounded interval.
So we need to show
that for every epsilon,
there exists a delta so that
no matter what two points--
So if you like, here's a picture
that goes along with this--
so that if I look at
maybe two points that
are close to each
other less than delta,
their function's value
is within epsilon.
And so let's say I'm
on an interval a, b.
But not just this point,
I could go over here
to two other points that are
within delta of each other.
And if I look at the function
evaluated at the two points,
then the difference
between these two guys
is also less than epsilon.
So I can move through
the party and as long
as I'm close enough within a
uniform distance to somebody,
I can hear them just fine.
So what a nice trip
down memory lane when we
could be around other people.
So let's show this function
is uniformly continuous.
Let epsilon be positive.
Choose delta to
be epsilon over 2.
Now, you see this delta
just depends on epsilon,
then if x and c are in 0, 1, and
x minus c is less than delta,
then if I compute
the difference, x
squared minus c
squared, I can write
as x plus c times x minus c.
And now I use the
triangle inequality,
this is less than or
equal to x minus c.
Now, these guys are in 0, 1,
so their absolute values always
bounded by 1.
So this is less than
or equal to 1 plus 1,
and then x minus c
is bounded by delta,
which equals 2 times
delta, and delta
is chosen to be epsilon over 2.
So I get epsilon.
Now, again, how would
you choose delta?
So it looks like I just chose
this delta out of nowhere.
In practice, how do
you choose delta?
This is the computation you do.
You take x squared minus
c squared, split it,
you have this.
You can estimate with what
you know above by 2 here
times delta.
So how do you choose delta
so that 2 times delta
is, say, equal to epsilon?
You choose delta to
be epsilon over 2.
So let's negate this
definition and then look at 1
over x once again
and check to see
if it's uniformly continuous.
We'll show it's not.
So the negation f from s to r
is not uniformly continuous.
So I saw a little bit of the
new Borat movie that came out.
So I almost wanted to say
f is uniformly continuous.
Not.
But I didn't.
It's not uniformly continuous.
And now you negate the
rest of the definition.
If there exists some bad
epsilon, such that no matter
what delta you choose, there
exists some bad x and c
and s, such that they're
close to each other,
but the values are not
bigger than or equal to.
So let's revisit 1 over x.
This is not uniformly continuous
on the open interval 0, 1.
So you see that this
function is continuous
but it's not
uniformly continuous.
We just proved that a minute
ago that it's continuous.
So let me now give you the
proof that this function is
not uniformly continuous.
And what's the idea behind this?
Here's one.
This is not to scale,
but there's one
as well, and 1 over x
shoots up to plus infinity
as x approaches 0.
So what uniform
continuity says is
that if I take any two
points in the interval that
are close to each
other, then the outputs
have to be close to each other.
Continuity, remember,
says if I fix a point,
then as long as I'm
close to that point,
the outputs will be
close to each other.
Uniform says, no
matter what two points
you choose, as long as
they're close together,
the outputs will be close
together in a controlled way.
Now, if I take two points
very close to each other here,
very close to 0, they can be
pretty close to each other.
I mean, their values
can be quite large.
Even though the difference
between the arguments
are small, the values
can be quite large
just because 1 over x shoots up.
So let's quantify this.
I have to tell you what
the bad epsilon not is.
Choose epsilon not equals 2.
Now, any epsilon not
will work just fine.
Let delta be positive.
So now we have to find x and
c and s within distance delta
to each other whose values
vary by at least two.
So let's choose c to be the
minimum of delta and 1/2,
and I'm going to choose
x to be c over 2.
So just ignoring this half for
a minute, c is equal to delta,
x is equal to delta
over 2, and then
1 over c minus 1 over x is
going to be 2 over delta.
And if delta is
very small, that's
certainly bigger
than or equal to 2.
But I had to throw in this 1/2
here because I chose epsilon
not to be 2, and
delta's arbitrary.
So then we see that
x minus c, this
equals c over 2, which is
certainly less than or equal to
since c is the minimum
of delta and 1 over 1/2
is less than delta over 2,
which is less than delta.
And if we compute 1 over x
minus 1 over c, this is--
remember x is c over 2, so
this 1 over x is 2 over c, so 1
over c.
And now from c being less
than or equal to 1 over 1/2m
I get that 1 over c is going to
be bigger than or equal to 2.
And that's the end of the proof.
So we see that even though
these two arguments are
very close to each other, the
outputs are, in fact, separated
by some fixed distance.
At least two.
But we could actually make it
bigger than 3, bigger than 4,
whatever you like.
And I'm not going to
go over this example.
But in fact, I'll leave
it to you or maybe I'll
put it on the
assignment, f of x equals
x squared is not
uniformly continuous on r.
So we saw that it's uniformly
continuous on a closed interval
0, 1, but it's not uniformly
continuous on all of r.
The reason being again
kind of because x squared
is starting to get big.
So I can take two things
close to each other,
stick it into x squared,
and their outputs
could be very different
from each other.
Didn't write out the
proof of this one,
so we're going to go by a little
bit by the seat of our pants.
So we want to show this is
not uniformly continuous.
So I think epsilon 0 equals
1 is going to work just fine.
Let delta be
positive, and the idea
is we want to choose
x to be some number.
Let's call it a plus--
well, c will be some number,
and c equals some number,
x equals c plus delta over 2.
So this is kind of scratch
work off to the side.
And let's see if we
can somehow choose c.
So first off, x minus
c will be delta over 2,
which is less than delta.
And now let's see
if we can choose c
so that x squared
minus c squared
is bigger than or equal to 1.
So c is kind of the thing
that we get to play with here.
I mean, this is how
it actually goes
if you want to figure out the
proof before you write it down,
the scratch work to the side.
So choose c so that this--
now, let's start
off with the thing
that we're trying
to bound from below
and start computing some stuff.
This is equal to x plus c--
and c will be positive.
So this will be c, and
x will be positive.
So x plus c times
x minus c; now x
plus c will be 2c plus
delta over 2; x minus c
will be delta over 2.
So far all of these
things are equality,
and we get this is
equal to 2c plus--
so delta is 2c plus
delta squared over 2,
and here we're going
to choose c positive.
So we're trying to show it's
not uniformly continuous on r.
So we just need to find a
value of c and a value of x so
that they're within delta
distance to each other,
but their outputs are
bigger than or equal to 1.
So far if c is just
something positive,
x is c plus delta over
2, then they're close.
Their difference,
however, is going
to be just by this computation
equal to 2c plus delta over 2
times delta over 2 squared.
Now delta squared over 2
is always non-negative,
so it's certainly bigger than
or equal to delta times c.
And now remember we
wanted this thing
to be bigger than or equal to 1.
Right now we have it's bigger
than or equal to delta c.
So let's choose c
to be 1 over delta,
and let's see that that works.
Choose c to be 1 over
delta, x to be 1 over delta.
So c plus delta over 2.
Then these two values are close.
x minus c equals delta
over 2 is less than delta,
and x squared minus c
squared equals x plus c times
x minus c.
x plus c as we did a minute
ago is going to be 2 over delta
plus delta over 2.
That's x plus c.
x minus c is equal
to delta over 2,
which equals 1, plus
delta squared over 4,
which is bigger than or
equal to 1, our bad epsilon.
So f of x equals x squared is
not uniformly continuous on r,
even though it is uniformly
continuous on this
closed and bounded interval.
So uniform continuity
is really a relationship
between a function and the
domain on which it's defined.
So this is kind of
to wrap up our theme
of continuous functions
and how they're
behaved on closed and
bounded intervals.
And we see here that
uniform continuity
is a much stronger notion
than continuity, as I've said.
I mean, you can easily
prove from the definition
that if a function is
uniformly continuous on s,
then it's continuous on s.
And we've seen that in general
the reverse inclusion does not
hold.
So let me just write
this up as a remark.
In general, f
uniformly continuous
implies that f is continuous.
This just follows
from the definition.
This is not difficult to show.
But the converse does not
hold, as we've just seen
We have two examples
here. f of x
equals 1 over x on the
open interval 0, 1, which
is continuous, but it's
not uniformly continuous;
and then we have the function
f of x equals x squared,
which is not uniformly
continuous on r.
But in fact, it is
uniformly continuous
on this closed and
bounded interval 0, 1.
This example here,
though, is, in fact,
the rule; that if I'm
looking at a function
on a closed and bounded
interval, then, in fact,
these two notions
are equivalent.
So that's the following theorem.
Let f be a function
from a to b to r.
So closed and bounded interval
now, not just an arbitrary set.
Then f is continuous
on a, b, meaning
it's continuous at
every point, if and only
if f is uniformly
continuous on a, b.
And the necessity of working on
a closed and bounded interval
is seen again by
this example we had
here of f of x
equals 1 over x and f
of x equals x squared
on r and 0, 1.
But as long as we're looking on
a closed and bounded interval,
continuous is equivalent
to uniform continuity.
Now, this is also not the
sharpest thing you can say.
In fact, what you can
say is that if I replace
this with what's called
a compact set, which
I may put in the
assignment, I may not,
then the statement
is still true.
And that's in some sense
the sharpest statement.
But I think this is
interesting enough
to just work on a closed
and bounded interval.
So let's prove this.
I leave this to you as an
exercise, uniform continuity
implying continuity.
I leave it to you.
And I will do more
difficult one,
and we'll use kind
of a philosophy
like we did in the
previous lecture
where we use the
definition of continuity
or this theorem about continuity
in terms of sequences and also
the Bolzano-Weierstrass theorem.
Good.
We still have the
negation of the definition
of uniform continuity, and
that's what we'll need.
So we're going to
prove f continuous
implies uniformly
continuous, and we're going
to do this by contradiction.
So suppose f is
continuous on a, b,
but not uniformly continuous.
And then we're going to
break the universe some way,
which shows that our assumption
that f is not uniformly
continuous does not hold.
So we use this negation
of the definition
of uniform continuity, which
says that there exists delta 0.
So let me write this out.
I'm just going to
rewrite this here,
then there exists a delta
0, such that for all delta
positive, there
exists x, c and a, b,
which depend on delta, such that
x minus c is less than delta
and f of x minus f
of c is greater than
or equal to epsilon not.
Now, this holds for every delta.
You can find x and c so that
x minus c is less than delta
and f of x minus
f of c is greater
than or equal to epsilon not.
So let's choose delta to be 1
over n for each natural number
n, and for all natural
numbers n, there exists
xn, cn, and a, b, such that--
so this is the statement now
with delta equals 1 over n.
xn minus cn is
less than 1 over n,
and f of x sub n minus f of c
sub n is bigger than or equal
to epsilon 0.
Now, I have two sequences
here, and they're
bounded because they're in this
closed and bounded interval.
So I can pass to a subsequence
of one of them to start
by the Bolzano-Weierstrass
theorem--
not B-Z, Bolzano-Weierstrass.
I think that's probably
somewhere else in the lecture
or the previous I wrote
B-Z, but I meant B-W
by Bolzano-Weierstrass--
there exists subsequent xn sub k
of x sub n and x and a, b, such
that limit as k goes to infinity
of x sub n sub k equals x.
So Bolzano-Weierstrass
from any bounded sequence
we can find a
convergent subsequence.
And because this subsequence
is always between a and b,
the limit x will
be between a and b.
Now, since the
subsequence cn sub k
is bounded between a and b--
so I have a subsequence
of x sub n sub k,
and I then obtain a
subsequence of the c sub n
by just picking these
integers to be the same.
And so now that
subsequence is of the c sub
n is they're all
coming from a, b.
So that's bounded by a, b.
So it's bounded.
So by Bolzano-Weierstrass
applied now
to this subsequence, there
exists a subsequence c sub n
sub k of j, of c sub n
sub k, and an element c
in a, b, such that
the limit as j
goes to infinity of c sub
n sub k sub j equals c.
So I found a subsequence
of the x of n's, and now I
look at a corresponding
subsequence of the c sub
n's where now the subsequent cn
sub k's are coming from the n
sub k's chosen for this
subsequence, that's
still a bounded sequence.
So by Bolzano-Weierstrass,
I can take
a subsequence of
that and an element
c so that I have convergence.
So now let me just summarize.
So in summary, the sequences
x sub n sub k of j--
so now this is even a
subsequence of x sub n sub k
and c sub n sub k sub j.
These are subsequences of
the original sequences x sub
n and c sub n.
And this x and c and a, b,
such that the limit as j
goes to infinity of x sub n
sub j equals x, and limit as j
goes to infinity of z
sub n sub kj equals c.
Now, I claim x equals c.
Now, 0 is certainly bigger than
or equal to x sub n sub k sub
j minus c sub n sub k
sub j, which is less
than or equal to by
how we've defined
these sequences is less than or
equal to 1 over n sub k sub j.
So first off, by the
definition of subsequences,
j is always bigger than
or equal to n sub k--
n sub k sub j is always
bigger than or equal to j.
So this is always less
than or equal to 1 over j.
This is just a consequence of
how some sequences are defined.
You always have to
move to the right
after you've made a choice
of entry in the sequence
that you're going to take as
an element of your sequence.
So 0 is bounded,
bounds this from below,
and is bounded above by 1
over j, which converges to 0.
So the middle thing has to
converge to 0 by the squeeze
theorem.
But these two things,
that converges to x, this
converges to c.
And so the absolute value
of x minus c equals 0,
and therefore x equals c.
Now, we're almost home free.
This limit as j goes to infinity
of x sub n sub k sub j equals
c, and limit as j goes
to infinity c sub n sub k
sub j equals c.
Now, where's the kicker?
This.
So these are subsequences
of x sub n and c sub n.
But each of those sequences
is converging to a number c.
So by the theorem
about continuity,
since f is continuous
at c, this implies
that 0 equals the limit
as j goes to infinity
of f of x sub n sub--
write it this way.
f of c minus f of c
equals limit j goes to infinity
of f of n's of c sub n sub k
sub j, which is bigger
than or equal to epsilon 0.
All of these are
supposed to be bigger
than or equal to some fixed
epsilon 0, which is positive.
But we've just shown
that's equal to 0.
And that's the contradiction.
Thus, f is uniformly
continuous on a, b.
So that concludes what
we'll say about continuity.
And as you'll note
kind of going forward,
we're going to
cover topics faster.
That's just because we have
more machinery to work with.
At the start it was very
slow going just because one,
it's the start of your
first proof based class.
So I'm going to
go slow; and two,
we didn't have
much to work with.
We just had the
real numbers are in
ordered field with the
least upper bound property.
But now we've covered sequences,
continuity we know more,
and it'll be easier to
prove new things and also
hopefully familiarity
with proofs
is getting better so
that my arguments can
be a little bit shorter
and not so involved.
So we're moving on
to something now.
This is supposed to
be about calculus.
We've covered
limits, continuity.
The next big topic has
to be differentiability.
So this is a new chapter
about the derivative.
So let me first give you
the precise definition.
So first off, I'll be
saying, let I be an interval,
f goes from I to R,
and c an element of I.
Now, when I say an
interval, I don't
mean it has to be closed
and bounded like ones
we've been working on.
I don't mean it has to be open.
It doesn't have to be a bounded
interval like from 0 to 1.
It could be 0 to infinity.
It can include the endpoints,
except, of course, infinity.
But I think what
I mean and I don't
have to write all this out for
what exactly an interval is.
So let I be an interval and f
be a function from I to R and c
a point of I.
So first off, convince
yourselves of this,
but I think it should
be pretty clear.
For an interval, every
point in the interval
is a cluster point
of the interval.
This is not too
difficult to prove.
And I will not require
you to prove it,
but I'm just saying
this because I'm
about to define a limit at c.
So it had better be a
cluster point of a set
that this limit
is defined using.
So of I, take away c.
And if you don't
like the statement,
just forget I even wrote
it and we'll continue on.
You say f is
differentiable at c--
so this is the new
bit of terminology.
If the limit x goes to c, f of
x minus f of c over x minus c
exists.
If this limit exists, we say the
functions differentiable at c,
and we use a notation f prime
f apostrophe c for this limit.
If f is differentiable at
every point of the interval I,
we'd get a new
function, this function
f prime of c, which we
denote the function that's
a derivative of f
as f prime or dfdx.
So the simplest guys that are
differential are, of course,
polynomials.
I think this is one of the
first things you learn back
in calculus.
And I'm not going
to go through what
this is supposed to represent.
You know this from
calculus, the best way
to say what this
number represents
is the instantaneous rate
of change of the function
f at this point.
How is f changing at that point
in the sense of increasing,
decreasing, and so on?
Or if you like,
you interpret this
as being the slope
of the line that
is perfectly
tangent to the curve
to the graph of the function f.
But what does that mean
to be tangent to the graph
of a function?
So that takes a
bit of explaining.
So I'm not going to get into
what the actual interpretation
of this number is.
I think you have a pretty
good idea of what that is.
We're just going to start
proving some properties of it.
So the simplest
example of a function
which is differentiable
is that of a monomial.
So f of x equals x to the n.
Let's put even a
number in there.
So let's write it this way.
Let f have been R in
the natural number 0,
then function f of x equals
alpha times x to the n
is differentiable.
So I should have
said here as well
if a function is
differentiable at every point
where it's defined,
or if a function is
differentiable at every
point in its domain I,
then we just say the
function is differentiable.
So then this monomial is
differential and for all
c f prime of c equals n times
alpha x to the n minus 1, c.
So let's give a proof
of that, and we'll
use this kind of simple formula.
So let's take a look
at x minus c times
this kind of weird looking
sum to x, n minus 1 minus j,
c to the j.
So multiply the x
through, I get sum from j
equals 0 to n minus 1, x to the
n minus j, c to the j minus--
and I'm not going to use
j again in the sum when
I carry this c through.
I'm going to use l--
sum from l equals 0 to n
minus 1, x to the n minus--
I'll put it this way-- j
plus 1, c to the j plus 1, l,
and now I'm going to make
a change of variables
in this second sum and
let j equals l plus 1.
So in that case, when l
equals 0, j starts at 1.
When l hits n minus
1, j equals n.
So this equals the sum from
j equals 0, n minus 1, x,
n minus j, c to the j minus sum
j equals 1 to n, x, n minus j,
c to the j.
So it's the same
terms in the sum,
except starting at
different places.
So what doesn't
get killed here is
the j equals 0 term because
this one starts at j equals 1.
This one ends at n.
And so it kills
the n minus 1 term.
So the only thing that
survives from this sum
is the j equals 0 term, x to
the n minus 0, c to the 0 minus.
And now from here, everything
gets killed except the n terms.
So x to the n
minus n, c to the n
equals x to the n
minus c to the n.
So this is therefore
equal to this.
So we use this to
compute this limit.
So then f prime of c
is equal to the limit
as x goes to c of
x to the n alpha
times x to the n times
alpha times c to the n,
where x minus c--
now, alpha is just a number.
It can pop out--
x to the n minus c to the
n divided by x minus c
is this thing
divided by x minus c.
So this is equal to alpha times
the limit as x goes to c of sum
from j equals 0 to n minus 1,
x to the n minus 1 minus j, c
to the j.
Now, this is just
a polynomial in x.
Polynomials are
continuous functions.
So the limit as x goes to c
is just to plug in c to x.
And so this equals
alpha times sum from j
equals 0 to n minus 1, c to
the n minus 1 minus j times
j equals--
so c to the n minus 1
minus j times c to the j
gives me c to the n minus 1--
I'm summing in j.
There's no j here, so
that just pops out--
times the sum j
equals 0, n minus 1.
And there's n of the times 1.
So this is just n.
And that's the proof.
So I'm sure you saw
that at some point.
Next time we'll give an example
of a function which is not
differentiable out of a point.
Of course, I think you
probably already know
this, f of x equals the
absolute value of x.
If there's time at
some point, I'll
go over an example
of a function, which
was very surprising to
people at one point.
So now that we have
differentiability
and continuity on the board, for
a long time since dead people
believed that if you have
a continuous function,
any continuous
function, then there
has to be at least one point
where it's differentiable.
There must be at least one
point where it's differentiable.
And people tried to prove
that for a long time
and they couldn't
because it's false.
Weierstrass, who was, again kind
of the godfather of everything
we're doing, came up with
a whole class of examples
of functions that
are continuous,
but are differentiable nowhere.
They're not differentiable
at a single point.
And perhaps depending on time,
will go over this example.
And think I'll stop there.